nunca fue mencionada sin embargo china
estuvo en el centro de esta reunión del
quad y su intento de extender su
influencia en el indo pacífico a través
del refuerzo de sus capacidades
militares la multiplicación de sus
ejercicios y maniobras cerca de
territorios disputados como taiwán la
extensión en varias islas del pacífico
en el himalaya en el mar chino y sus
nuevas rutas de la seda' la extensión
militar y económica chinas preocupan a
estados unidos australia japón y ainia
sus dirigentes se reunieron en tokio
donde yo ver en provecho solidaridad en
caso de un ataque de beijing bueno
estamos viviendo una hora oscura de
nuestra historia común somos potencias
siendo pacíficas y como les he dicho
estaremos a su lado ustedes nuestros
socios demócratas vamos a defender los
valores que compartimos todos una
declaración que match hizo tras haber
asegurado el día interior que eeuu
estaba listo para intervenir
militarmente en taiwán en caso de una
invasión china provocando la furia de
beijing la reunión del 4 durante una
década ya que australia había tomado
distancia fue también la ocasión para
reforzar los lazos económicos de interés
white prospect creo que existen grandes
posibilidades para una cooperación
económica más global en toda una serie
de esferas un ámbito que me obsesiona el
tren a alta velocidad en australia en
ningún país hizo eso mejor que japón con
el cinc en sant de alcanzar tras el
encuentro los cuatro países anunciaron
un programa de vigilancia marítima para
promover la estabilidad y la prosperidad
en la región